so I'm now in a game and I'm ready to
get started but first we need to make
our character so the first chart says
male or female hmm which one would have
me better chance to survive since no one
is independent on strength I'm gonna go
with the most manly I possibly could
actually no I'm gonna make I'm gonna
make a recreation of Who I am and I
appreciate the pure doom guy ESCA nature
of this dude so as far as I am and what
I am I've got a neck the size of a
long-long like my will to survive just
some impinged shoulders to submit some I
like to call them aerodynamic so I can't
stop staring at that neck man upper face
sighs oh man that is too funny Jesus
Christ all right so all the features I'm
picking are supposed to be perfectly
replication of me and Who I am and all
of you I know I know every single one of
you out there is standing with my neck
can you even see a difference between
the two of us no you cannot
it is impossible with my aerodynamic
shoulders in my aerodynamic neck I will
do whatever it takes to survive
Hedwig crank that [ __ ] head height
enormous head depth don't even know what
that means oh all of my neck is
dedicated to keeping my head aloft in
proper surviving position hips
narrow nice valve time I'd say torso
height okay I think I think I got a nice
look I got a nice a nice nice compact
Tour's oh yeah oh oh nice and compact
yeah really accentuate the the boobs
they're a source of depth but concave
but concave I think now let's make that
good our leg length wow that's that's
more true to life huh that's more true
to lively let's pick the doors are a
little bit taller yeah it's good this is
going well arms hands huge upper legs
massive lower legs not as big foot giant
arm length group okay arm length epic
upper arm bulging whoa not that bulging
lower arm big okay Popeye let's get that
big under control there that's more it's
not natural but those legs
oh those buns have a sweet thighs yeah
imma save this can I save this as true
mark that's what he is all right
there's no changing for a hair just hair
color yeah let's go that good they don't
have a red option don't need that weird
brown there we go all right survivor
named mark if plier
spawn region I don't know South Zone to
whatever that is I'm just gonna go with
that one Zeus
no oh god damn oh good thing I saved it
I'm a smarty all right there we go
create a new survivor
I am the real markiplier whoever wants
to try to kill me please do your best
Oh
uh-huh oh hey nice screeching scratch
man that is just like crazy well here I
am world it's time for you to accept Who
I am and understand that me am ready to
serve oh is that a bird I'm gonna kill
you
I said dodo I'm gonna punch the [ __ ] out
of you
you didn't even once right man oh [ __ ]
putting up a fight huh whoa [ __ ] what
yeah yeah you think you can you think
you can get away without me whooping
somebody's whoa top rubber man and all
over the waist don't even try
that's right oh what's that dead I
thought so gender female mate boosted I
killed a level 110 dodo you think
anything in this world is gonna stop me
when I can kill a dodo of a level 110
with my bare fists I don't think so
oh it's unconscious okay well I suppose
I better eat it well all right this
feels wrong I'm gonna keep doing it
maybe I'll level up
I did level up I didn't even know
leveling up was a thing that could
happen I'm going to okay then I guess
I'll take that I think what the hell is
all this what is I don't know what all
this is ah can I get some meat off of
this I guess it has no meat there was
literally no point in murdering that
dodo I should have done better welp I'm
off to a bad start if this is how I'm
gonna do this oh hey all right then just
gonna yeah change one option yeah that
one note that can go please all right
then well now that I've killed something
oh is that a fellow survivor I don't
trust him I don't trust him at all
where's my uh where's my how do i how do
I talk to people that's important to
know ah push-to-talk it's B whoa
what the Frick was I defecated why did i
defecate I didn't even press add okay
anyway so I need to get through here
okay Bob apparently lives here so what I
need to do is I need to make my way
inland access inventory to apply it Oh
shooty oh oh okay all right
that's how I level up oh hell yeah you
know what I'm gonna level up as
amazingly a killer level 110 you think
anything's gonna stop me yes absolutely
I don't know how many points I have I
don't even see that stamina up what is I
don't know I've got Engram points yeah
what does costumes mean I don't [ __ ]
know okay you know what I level up
that's all that matters I'm going
England because I gotta survive I'm
going England I'm going inland because I
can't okay there we go man there's dinos
around here see this is the thing I've
never played this game I've only watched
someone play at once and I believe those
Ross so what I'm going into this
blind it doesn't even begin to describe
the kind of blind that I am also how do
I craft also what is that what is with
that there's a raft next to a giant
floating obelisk in the sky if there's
some sort of wealth inequality here I
can see it plain as day this is [ __ ]
also what's with the weird glowy thing
those were the words of weird bright
thing in this guy never seen that before
don't worry I'm gonna live out my life
I'm gonna live all out I'm gonna live
loud in my life here in the woods can I
punch the tree oh hell yeah I can the
answer is no it isn't it whoa I punched
a tree down better than I thought I was
oh man yeah I'm just kidding I'm just
paying back the world for what it's done
to me it owes me something it owes me
apparently this is hurting my help you
know what I don't care it's gonna make
me tougher in the long run all right so
let's see what I can make with this
fetch craftable x' ooh I could use that
I need a stone where do I get a stone
probably from punching a rock yeah well
that's not a punchable Rock is this a
collectible Rock man how do I get an
appropriate is this a collectible oh
yeah okay all right I need to stop
pressing tab for that but I got this and
me Marga Boyer and make pickaxe crafted
oh hell yeah I'm crafting it up you
think I can't craft I know exactly the
craft
I'm the craftiest son of a [ __ ] that
ever did walk this arc land oh and I'm
done was talking too much
didn't even know I was done but hey look
at this I've got me a freaking stroke
I'm the best survivor that ever did walk
this world I'm the best survivor to ever
know anything this land there's one
thing that I do know and it's not a lot
he said I am the master of the
environment that I've been put in why am
I still talking I don't even know
anymore
all I know is if this rock bird come on
here the gooble gobble of a bird I
defecated well I mean that's another
point to make in a different world
no go you think you can mess with me
wild female dodo wanna beat [ __ ] out of
you oh you think you can mess my stone
pick knows no fury
you think mercy is in my vocabulary when
leveling up is at stake you will die and
you will know death feel it upon your
skin don't don't run from me dodo I know
where you live I can find you I'll [ __ ]
all over your life friend you can run
you thought I would forget you think I
would forgive barely I should get some
warm I'm gonna take it from your blood I
got some Flint from you apparently I
don't know how or why ya did it may get
some meat from that I'm really hungry
did I get anything from that did I get
anything from that I got hide that
doesn't help me at all but I need
apparently I need to make some more
stone pigs why am I in pain huh why am I
in pain what am i in pain from is it coz
the cold I'm hungry hmm big [ __ ]
alright so I gotta find a way to get
food somehow or else I'm gonna die who
cares
alright what have we got here Suns going
down
gotta find food before it's too late
dodo no I'm gonna leave you merciful
again whoa did I just see I must be
getting delirious because I'm seeing
visions in the distance and I don't like
it I gotta find something that I can
kill and then eat because this ain't
working for me
I mean why can't I kill the dodo yeah
I'm gonna kill you just because I got
nothing better to do and hopefully I'll
be able to get some meat out of you I'm
sorry I'm killed two of you already I've
tasted blood and I just can't be stopped
I'm a literal monster assemble the dodo
police and catch me I want to be caught
Oh
broke okay all right well I'll make it I
I got another one so that's that's good
all right don't worry my murder weapon
is back if you're thinking that it was
over is not the nightmare continues
you're going to die okay three raw meat
there we go finally yes Rahmi
what happened to the last meat I was
trying to get me this whole time I
wasn't giving me me pork all right I
gotta get some all right so let's make a
torch ooh yes please
my health is going down okay oh this
makes so much more oh that makes so much
more sense
oh hell yeah okay so that was important
so now I need two things are going very
badly for me I keep pressing tab I got
to change that yeah I don't have much
time okay crap that crap that okay man I
am doing bad shape ooh boy okay that
sounds awful I don't like the sound of
that at all okay this there this there
all right okay put this down oh my god
don't die please please don't die oh my
god am I gonna die would light it light
fire what am i dying of what am i dying
of oh I see in colors I see a vision oh
boy I'm not doing well oh I have a
broken bone I have a broken bone I have
a broken bone what I have a broken bone
it's [ __ ] I don't know what I did I
don't know how to fix it I got a cooked
meat here I'm gonna eat that as quickly
as I can
oh my hell are you coming back up ooh
maybe my broken bone is gonna mend
itself somehow I think it's cuz I was
indeed starving
I might have been starving
that's not for me to decide I think I
think I think starving is a bit of a I
think starved is a bit of a rough way to
say about things I think I'm doing
pretty good
I need fiber so where do I get fiber how
do I get fiber I need more fiber in my
life how do I get fiber do I gotta axe
up some [ __ ] okay well can't see anyt in
alright I got a torch I'm gonna put it
there I'm just gonna swell wildly okay
then I'm gonna go back and camp and eat
some food because I'm starving again
now how crowd much food do I need I mean
I know my neck needs a lot of sustenance
but this is just ridiculous they're a
goddamn ridiculous give me my charcoal I
don't know that's gonna do cook beat
sure I'll take it alright they're gonna
actually do something for me it's not
gonna actually do something for me huh
you gotta let me be your let B be be ah
alright fine what the [ __ ] is that what
is that what is that some sort of light
just floating in the sky oh that's a
weird single color moon what are you in
the ocean are you mocking me what is
that what is that I I'm gonna find out
what that is but I just don't know yet
I'm gonna get there but just bear with
me okay so amazingly amazingly I'm not
dead yet which is incredible I don't
know how that happened but I'm not dead
so I'm gonna take this as a win and I'm
gonna end this episode here while I'm
still alive and then carry on to another
one because the survival does not stop
in a single episode of arc I'm gonna
carry on for a long time I'm gonna own
this island and I'm gonna do that
through negotiating skills with all the
other players here I'm a smooth-talking
in this love
I sure hope my all chat just hasn't been
on this whole time because then people
have been hearing me blabbing about us
to myself but I think they're gonna come
to respect the Great and Powerful
markiplier when he comes down here and
they seem to be busy talking about real
life stuff so honestly who cares but
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for believing in
me
there's a lot more left on this island
to take care of so I'll get to that very
soon so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]